what is the question it people in that
situation should be asking themselves
and how do they take that first step in
transformation from becoming the banker
that's in the city with a suit and tie
on right now listening to this to the
person that would make them whole and
full and and love themselves in their
life I think that question is probably
different for everybody but how about
just asking yourself
who are you and I mean that in the
broadest sense but I also mean it in the
very tangible sense of like what are you
doing are you really on the path that
you want to be on did you choose this
path are you here because of external
pressures and I think when you turn
inward and start exploring your interior
and developing a lattice work or an
understanding of what those mechanics
are sets you on a trajectory to making
better decisions for yourself